good afternoon everybody welcome to the
Macmillan Center I'm in Shapiro it's
director we're delighted to host Sergio
hamari okaro former high commissioner
for peace in Colombia as a speaker for
the coca-cola world fund lecture at Yale
this lecture was established in 1992 by
the late Roberto Wayzata former chair
and CEO of the coca-cola company and
Yale class of 1953 mr. hi amira doesn't
know it but he's actually being in this
room once before but it was at a
conference where he was giving a keynote
address and because he was in the thick
of negotiations at the time he couldn't
actually get here and so you you
actually spoke from this screen to this
room so welcome back to the the
Macmillan Center
he's the man who negotiated the historic
peace accord in Columbia as the Columbia
High Commissioner for peace he served as
the Colombian government's chief
strategist throughout the peace process
spending six years in intense
negotiations with Columbia's largest
group gorilla gorilla group the
Revolutionary Armed Forces of Colombia
which we all know of as the FARC and
together with Umberto he led the public
negotiations for four years in in Havana
which ended in the signing of the final
agreement in November of 2016 the
Colombian Congress approved the peace
accord with the FARC in December of 2016
ending one of the world's longest
running civil conflicts he also oversaw
the disarmament and demobilization
process of the FARC which in which ended
in August of 2017 when the UN
verification mission extracted the last
container of weapons from far from the
FARC cantonment area we saw before
serving in that role Mr Jaramillo
served as the vice minister of defense
for policy and international affairs
where he taught the way he sought to
establish the state pressure presence in
violent territories throughout Colombia
he's also served in a wide array of
other government positions throughout
his career including as advisor for the
ministry of foreign affairs in charge of
the diplomacy for peace program and the
political advisor at the Embassy of
Colombia in France in addition to his
service in government he was executive
director of the ideas for peace
foundation and most recently he served
as Colombian ambassador to the EU and
Belgium from 2017 to 2018 and so he's
going to be speaking to us today he'll
speak for about 45 minutes and then
we'll probably have about a half an hour
of questions and discussion will end
promptly at 6:00 after which there will
be a reception upstairs to which
everybody is in what is invited the
title of today's lecture is peace and
justice the case of Colombia I'm pleased
to introduce Sergio Horomia Caro welcome
[Applause]
well thank you very much for that
introduction
Ian is is great to finally get here to
be at Yale and to see friends and you
origins professor Fitz and Elizabeth
whom I see back there somewhere thank
you very much for coming and thank
everyone from the Macmillan Center your
fabulous secretary Lourdes and Nikolas
and Greg and everyone who worked to make
this visit possible my subject today is
the relation between peace and justice
for countries such as Colombia that
suffered a long and protracted conflict
a so called intractable conflict of more
than 50 years that caused massive
suffering think just of the fact that we
have more than seven million IDPs
I think there's hardly a more pressing
issue in fact it was the hardest point
to agree on in the final agreements that
we ended up finding with the FARC in
November of 2016 but perhaps for other
countries as well this is of interest
you don't need to be a particularly
sharp observer to notice as many have
done that the world is today in the
state of disarray we see the symptoms of
change but we don't understand the
causes of change
I think but one thing we do understand
is that the issue of migration has given
a new lease of life to a far-right
politics that seemed buried in the past
from Italy and Germany to Colombia and
soon Brazil far-right parties have
gotten to office or become major
opposition parties by feeding off and
exploiting migration that is often
associated of the conflict as in the
case of the war
Syria or by scaring voters with the
prospect of state collapse and civil
arrests itself and brandishing the
example of Venezuela that is happening
in South America so it's perhaps a good
time I think to think about the relation
between peace and justice because this
crisis is sorry you're not just about
justice but justice has been a major
part of them I should limit my remarks
to our own experience in Colombia but I
shall not limit myself to what has come
to be known as transitional justice
certainly in the peace negotiations we
made as much use of transition with
justice doctrine and practice as we
could possibly more than anywhere else
but transitional justice in the standard
definition of accountability for crimes
passed is only one side of the coin in a
peace process and transitional justice
especially in my view is unfinished
business first as part of the grave the
first and great Special Rapporteur of
transitional justice of the UN a
Colombian national and a good friend
pointed out in one of his last reports
transitional justice doctrine
unthinkingly transposed a model of
accountability for authoritarian regimes
to post-conflict contexts and the
differences are many the grave points to
the common weakness of institutions in
conflict ravaged regions which makes the
implementation of measures much more
difficult to the much larger volume of
victims you can in post-conflict
contexts or to the fact that often in
such contexts perpetrators may well have
been before themselves victims and the
list could be expanded of the
differences take for example the fact
which which louise are bore the former
High Commissioner of Human Rights of the
UN and a good friend of the Colombian
peace process pointed out in some lucid
remarks about a decade ago that
socio-economic rights
maybe equally important in a
post-conflict context as civil and
political rights and yet have not been
properly incorporated into transitional
justice doctrine the hard truth is that
for a family to be up loose it's loose
its land and end up living in a
shantytown in Colombia maybe ask
traumatic as losing a loved one
in fact the threat of displacement was
often used by armed groups as a tool of
forced recruitment but the thing is that
once you go down that road and this is
my second point everything may end up
becoming part of a transitional justice
program and the concept of transitional
justice may end up becoming or risk
becoming empty or even counterproductive
certainly in a peace process you can
implement many measures that I would
call young faced that is there they can
be both backward looking justice
measures and forward-looking peace
building measures and I will give some
examples later on but transitional
justice on its own cannot provide the
shared vision of a future that is
critical to a peace process and third
and this is my main point transitional
justice or post-conflict justice or use
postbellum or whatever expression you
wish to use tends to concentrate on the
justice bit and take for granted the
transition but what if the transition
itself depends on the justice formula
that is the situation we faced in the
negotiations in Havana and that is what
I want to talk about today in the time I
have left in particular I want to
highlight the potential that a peace
agreement has to achieve to achieve the
right marriage of justice and peace
through work through what I shall call
through what I shall call a dovetailing
strategy the problem of marrying peace
and justice
is not one of conceptual coherence again
it is easy to see how justice measures
can support peace building measures and
vice versa
the problem is that in a real
negotiation and a real transition there
are great tensions between peace and
justice that in some transitions may
amount to superable obstacles take for
starters the fact that in the case of
our own negotiations in Havana the
members of the FARC Secretariat that we
were facing across the table and who are
supposed to lead their organization into
peace and peaceful politics are also by
today's standards of criminal
responsibility those most responsible
for the crimes committed by their
organization now what do you do about
that I shall describe succinctly seven
strategies were used to achieve a
maximum of justice in the agreement the
first move was to establish the right
framework which meant first that
President Santos publicly recognized the
fact that in Colombia there was an
internal armed conflict string as it may
sound because there are massive military
operations in Colombia and the Air Force
bomba has their own territory the
previous government of whom president
Uribe denied there was an armed conflict
but without that horizontal structure
that comes with the conflict and
negotiation it's it's impossible to
negotiate an agreement and this had I
think at least three major compacta
co-benefits the first is that it said
the right legal framework for the
negotiations which is IHL international
humanitarian law so you can just you can
distinguish clearly between what's licit
and illicit contact under the law of war
now naturally as is well known a state
still also has additional human rights
obligations in the case of an internal
armed conflict but at least we have a
general framework and that was a
courageous decision by President Santos
because it meant that the government and
this is a key point was willing to
discuss also the violations or
infractions that may have been committed
by state agents secondly establishing
this framework conferred the necessary
dignity on the other side with which
without which a negotiation is not
possible as Jeremy Waldron might say
dignity confers a status or rank which
in my view is what opens the door to
transformation would dignity come right
for example you it's you have the right
to insist that anything that's written
has to be agreed by both sides
it may be seem obvious but it isn't it's
a pre principal of a negotiation but
equally calm obligations the simple fact
that you are supposed to comply with
whatever you agree to and that is a very
powerful tool and thirdly the framework
of the conflicts of the core of the
conflict allowed us to establish the
right narrative which was the end of the
conflict and it's non-repetition the end
of the conflict and is non-repetition
in 2012 we conducted six months of
secret negotiations in havana I was
myself ahead of the government's
delegation at the end of which we
produced a framework agreement that
wasn't just the roadmap for the
subsequent public talks but it was a
framework for long repetition which
combined measures of role development
with political participation with
justice with security so that this
concept of non-repetition or non
recurrence became the bridge between
peace and justice
between entitlement claims and needs
claims in a piece versus it was in any
case our umbrella and our PolarStar it
defined the agenda of everything we did
the second strategy and probably the
cornerstone of the whole thing was to
put the victims at the center of the
talks we spent many weeks during the
secret talks persuading the fact at the
farc that there had to be a point on
victims in the peace agreement in fact
it was the first time so far as I know
ever that a peace negotiation has had a
point on victims and this allowed us to
do three things first psychologically it
made it easier for the FARC to discuss
justice issues it was only indirectly
about them even if the investigations
will inevitably lead to those most
responsible conversely as I said the
government agreed that we had to discuss
the rights of all victims because it was
about the end of the whole armed
conflict so if we're going to achieve
non-repetition
and avoid vengeance we need to look
after the rights of all victims and this
gave the FARC the confidence to step
onto the stage because they knew they
weren't alone everyone else was also
accountable to the extent they may have
been responsible secondly by putting
victims at the center it gave us in my
view an adequate measure of what it
means to fight impunity in a transition
to peace that is an adequate response to
victims rights to choose justice
reparations and non-repetition across
the board if your standard of justice is
ordinary sentences under peacetime
conditions or what you might call
Victor's justice as was probably the
case in Yugoslavia then you cannot deny
the
the impunity gap naturally no gorilla is
going to accept to stand before an
ordinary court and receive a 40-year
sentence a peace process but if you are
standard it one has what has been
achieved in previous negotiations and
especially the needs of the victims and
of the peace process itself then I dare
say that we probably achieved more than
an ever been done before
third by putting victims at the centre
we were guaranteeing their active
participation and this may have been the
most important move we already had a
precedent because about eight months
before the secret talks started
President Santos had sanctioned before
the secretary-general of the United
Nations Ban ki-moon a new law law 14:48
known as the victims law which in its
itself was a product of the work of the
victims movement so we had a favorable
context and what we did is we organized
first when we started discussing the
point on victims this happened in June
of 2014 we organized with the help of
the United Nations office in Columbia
and of the University a national we
organized for lunch for large
conferences in different parts of the
country so that victims could come and
and send their proposals and at the end
of that exercise in a big rush the UN
and the University energy now we put
together all of this in a big pile of
books we would receive boxes full of
about 12 volumes with the victims
proposals that was very important we did
other things like opening a virtual
mailbox that people could send in their
opinions or suggestions but certainly
the most powerful thing we did was to
invite 60 victims to Havana in five
delegations of
12 each over a period of about 12 months
and this was certainly the most
emotional and powerful moment of the
whole of the negotiations the victims
were chosen by the church the UN and the
remediates the Nacional according to
certain criteria reflect the variety of
victims and I will just give you three
brief examples so you can visualize what
happens this was a kind of live truth
commission in the middle of peace
negotiation in the first allegation
there was a lady called Constanza to do
by her eldest brother had been kidnapped
and killed by the FARC in 1995 her
younger brother and her mother were
taking of a car in the middle of a
country road by the FARC in 2001 and
shot on the spot faced down and this in
the middle of a peace process that were
talks with the FARC then known as the
Goguen she herself had to leave Colombia
and has since lived in exile in
Switzerland and this was the first time
she had actually faced the FARC she said
in very emotional intubation I remember
she literally almost fainted that this
for her was the most important moment of
the talks that what she wanted was to
find out all the truth and she also said
that she was prepared to pardon - pardon
the FARC because she wanted to liberate
herself from this anger that she carried
all these years on what you might call
the opposite side another lady called
Jamila
a Galarraga from puta madre which is an
area in colombia on the periphery of
colombia on the border of the Ecuador
described how her father had been killed
by the paramilitary in 1990 how ten
years later her three sisters had been
raped
tortured and dismembered by the
paramilitary who'd then subsequently
acknowledged this crime at a terrible
time in Colombia when she said that it
would literally fish bodies out of the
rivers in Putumayo and yet and yet she
said that she was very happy I'm proud
to have been to Havana because she
wanted to clean her sister's names and
to make visible the tragedy of forced
disappearance and one last example a
very bitter one for us as government
from a very courageous woman called was
Maria Bernal who was the mother of a 26
year old who live in the south of Bogota
her son she called a boy in the body of
an adult probably had Down syndrome and
this this man boy in 2008 was I was
myself then Deputy Minister of Defense
so I know a lot about this was lured
away from but what that to a kind in the
north of the country and was shot and
passed for a dead gorilla in a kind of
mad body count strategy which became
known as the false positives and with
which we President Santos's Minister and
myself as Deputy Minister had to deal
was with some very hard and harsh
measures and all she wanted for herself
was justice that's what we saw in Havana
from these testimonies and we said as we
said so often they reminded us of why we
were sitting there negotiating with the
FARC and in many ways I think became the
what I would call the the moral center
of the peace process
the thirst strategy to deal with this
justice issue was to do what I would
call turning constraints into enablers
let me explain
in January of 2015 Umberto Alec Ali and
myself went to Havana on our own to see
the Fox Secretariat and sat with them
for three days in a safe house
discussing the hard issue of criminal
justice and we started by saying look
you have X number of sentences all of
you we're sitting here in front of us
you may or may not know that the
inter-american system of Human Rights
has spent the last decade forcing
Parliament's across the continent to
knock down amnesty laws you probably
know that Colombia is under preliminary
examination at the ICC and in any case
we are signatories of the Rome Statute
and we will stand by our obligations in
fact I think the ICC has so far played
in a very constructive role in the case
of Colombia precisely by exerting this
kind of close supervision of the process
and making everyone including us aware
that they are there watching and so we
said what are we going to do about that
because a blanket amnesty is completely
off the table and especially because
above and beyond our international
obligations the Colombian people are not
going to stand by a solution in this
agreement that does not include a
measure of justice so we said the most
serious crimes must be investigated and
accounted for and we should set up a
tribunal to deal with that the FARC
isn't carefully and at first were
relieved to have had a frank discussion
with us but subsequently like the
proverbial ostrich bird their hands
their heads in the sand because they
were literally paralyzed
and we insisted we are sorry but these
are the constraints of doing a peace
process in the 21st century and we had
to engage the help of lots of others it
wasn't enough for the government to be
speaking so for example the Norwegians
with a lot of foresight created a group
of international advisors that would
meet with with the FARC lawyers to
discuss possible ways forward with
regard to justice and this would get
back to the FARC then president Santos
had the idea of setting up a group of
lawyers so that there would be a team of
government lawyers and him afar close to
sit down because this is just too
sensitive to discuss directly a
monster's Louis was a very good and very
nice American Human Rights expert Doug
castle who's in Chicago he took us a
year and a half to reach an agreement of
victims the longest by far but it was I
think because it took that long for
reality to sink in these are the
constraints that we must observe if we
were going to reach a sustainable
agreement the fourth strategy was to
agree on what we called a comprehensive
system of justice truth reparations and
non-repetition
which includes a Truth Commission
includes a special jurisdiction and a
tribunal includes a new special unit to
look for the missing and that has
appeared and a whole series of
reparation measures and that system is
running today beginning to work today as
we speak the the special jurisdiction is
holding public audiences for victims of
kidnapping because they need to gather
all this information to be ready when
the farc and others go before them now
in order for the system to work and this
is the fifth strategy you need it
you need a series of incentives and a
series of what we call in Spanish
conditionalities of conditions the
incentives is that you get a maximum
sentence of eight years under special
conditions you live and remain in a
restricted area under UN monitoring and
you have to perform various kinds of
reparatory and restorative actions you
participate in reconstruction you
participate in de mining for example you
perform various acts of recognition of
your responsibilities before the victims
and so forth in a way which responds to
the victims right and they're also
further the goals of the peace process
and we have to tell the whole and
detailed truth of what you're done if
you don't then you expose yourself to
spending 20 years in prison those are
the incentives now the conditions or
conditionalities are that in order to
get that special treatment not only do
you have to appear before the
jurisdiction and answer all their
questions and tell the truth but you
have to participate in all the various
mechanisms of the system in the truth
commission or see for example if the
special unit that's starting to look for
the disappeared calls you it is your
duty to respond and if the jurisdiction
finds that you're not doing this then
you may lose your special treatment so
that the conditionalities regime as the
tribunal has called it in a recent and
exemplary decision of the appeals
chamber is actually what I would call
the engine room of the whole system
because it makes the wheels turn if you
want to get this special treatment then
you have to actually go and do all of
these things and that in itself which is
something we put into the agreement and
was then was put into a constitutional
reform and subsequently was developed in
all the relevant legislation
that's what's going to guarantee that
these various measures as the doctrine
would have it a transitional justice
really dovetail and that we really
respond to victims rights across the
board because when list unless they
really do that whoever goes before this
system they will not get their special
treatment the sixth strategy about which
I will always say a word was to embed
this system within the larger project of
non-repetition that is actually the
final agreement based on a territory
approach so the idea is everything we
agree to whether it is rural development
or alternative development for the coca
fields or for example the work that
truth commission may do on the ground
the idea is that this would all happen
in a in a coordinated manner as possible
in a given region so that there's
various measures you are implementing
reinforce each other and you actually
bring transformation of those regions
and you build a basis for peace building
let me just give you two examples of
this what I've called dovetailing now we
agreed to set up 16 regional development
programs with a territory approach which
are very ambitious development programs
which are supposed to be implemented
precisely in the hardest hit regions so
far about 150,000 people 150,000 have
already participated in various kinds of
meetings in order to build the regional
development plans in a true
participatory planning process and now
precisely because the regions that were
chosen were those that were hardest hit
by the conflict and where you had the
highest number of victims you can see
these programs in two ways you can see
them as forward-looking
development programs where you bring the
community together and you get them to
speak with each other and you open a
space for various people to meet and
discuss which did not exist before in a
logic of coexistence if not
reconciliation but you're also
acknowledging that you're doing this
because of what happened in the past so
that's actually what I meant
earlier on by this sort of Yanis phased
backward and forward looking measures
said you could not you do something that
has a parrot or a character you're there
because you acknowledge your suffering
but it's also forward-looking and it's
run as a development program equally we
agree to set up 16 special districts
that Congress unfortunately has yet to
approve that would give special
representation in Congress for two
legislators two people chosen from those
regions again with the same logic a
logic of territorial integration of
those regions but also a logic of
recognition of the suffering they went
through and as a form of collective
political reparations in any case from
the point of view of non-repetition in a
transition to peace it is probably far
more effective in my view to make sure
that a 16 year old especially in this
very unstable regions where you have
organized crime cocoa fuels and so forth
it's probably far more effective to
guarantee that a 16 year old stays in
school and then afterwards finds
employment or that a former combatant is
properly reintegrated into society than
to hand out very stiff forty year
sentences that probably nobody will
paying very much attention to in those
regions anyway and to the extent that
all the measures in the agreement are
rights based you can say that the
transitional justice program is in the
end embedded or nested in a larger
program to aggress to address and
activate citizens rights in those
regions in what amounts to in my view or
what you might call a true rossion
conception
of Justice vii and large strategy and
the data will end was to make
transitional justice compatible with
political participation and here is what
the tensions were and our greatest a
cardinal principle of the peace process
was that the FARC had to give up all of
its weapons before it would be allowed
to enter into politics we did not want
to repeat through a horrific mistakes of
the past in the 1980s in the first major
peace president of the FARC they had
created a a political party as part of
the process but they stayed under arms
and they come in a very evil combination
of paramilitaries drug traffickers and
state agents it has to be said combined
to wipe out this new party in a brutal
fashion the Union patriotic ax and the
guilt is is theirs but it has to be also
be said that the fact that the FARC were
under arms created a very tricky
environment and they also have their
part of responsibility so we had to we
wanted to avoid that and we insisted you
won't participate in politics unless
you've disarmed and they did in fact the
FARC disarmed in an exemplary manner in
six months they handed over all the
weapons to the UN monitoring mission
which was in Colombia with the UN
Security Council mandate and they and
they disarmed so quickly precisely
because they wanted to participate in
politics because they wanted to
participate in 2018 elections and that
is actually a very good thing a study by
Charles Cove has showed that almost all
of these stable peace processes over the
last thirty years included political
participation of former combatants in
fact it was the main predictor of
success and from the point of view of
the guerrillas that is how you justify
giving up your weapons how
justified to themselves and how they
carry their organization with them we're
now going to fight for our ideas in
democracy but no point of the agreement
has raised more controversy despite the
fact that Colombia has extensive
experience with political reintegration
of former combatants curiously a former
m-19 guerrilla Gustavo Petro just came
in second in the elections and yes and
yet when it comes to the FARC there's
been a source of massive opposition from
the critics of the peace process and it
is in fact still one of the main sources
of or one of the main threats I would
say to the stability of the peace
process if that door were closed but
what do you do how do you marry these
two things so the way out was shown by
the Constitutional Court in a recent
judgment which Salim Anarkali extended
the conditionalities regime that
attached to getting a special treatment
in terms of criminal judgment just as
they extended that to political
participation so you can actually sit in
Congress
according to the agreement the FARC were
given five seats in the Senate and five
seats in the chamber if they did not win
those seats in the elections which they
didn't so they have them now so the
court has said you can sit in Congress
so long as you fully comply with your
obligations towards the comprehensive
system how that's going to work we don't
know but if they don't they will lose
that right to participate in politics
it's not a perfect solution but it is
the best you can do if you want a
transition to peace to succeed thank you
very much
thank you very much
so sometimes we call these transitions
the end of the beginning rather than the
end so why don't we open it up to the
floor for questions and you can ask
about any aspect but we do want
questions or not speeches
yeah so I have two questions one face
for me and honestly one for my BOB so so
my first question is for the closet so
you know obviously as you know called
Columbia vote he's free to go for
colonies thought and although narrowly
the the majority was no Colombians voted
no for the EC oh uh how was that for you
like what was the after working so hard
on this deal for so many years what was
that like for you
the second question so again with my mom
I'll be honest she's against you voted
no for the deal how do you how do you
talk to you know you real-life common
Colombians who were affected by fighting
apart and how do you tell them that that
this is you know the way to go that I
realized criminal justice
Anala that that's kind of like the way
to go especially since you know the part
committed so many atrocities how do you
convince that necessarily like like us
in the crowd but the back fold commerce
Claudia be bossed around okay well as
you might imagine that's a big chapter
the whole issue of the referendum you
asked me first what it was like for me
well frankly is like when you go through
something extremely tricky that
he's only much later realize how tricky
it was I didn't realize it was a very
very sensitive thing but I remember we
were on on the plane back to Havana
because this we lost the figures are the
13 and a half million Colombians voted
and we lost by 60,000 votes so we lost
by 0.3 of a percent but we lost so
naturally what he do is a good Democrat
which is a president that Santos did was
you can go on television you say we've
lost and acknowledged the result and so
I was sent with him back to la calle
next day to Havana by the president to
talk to the FARC and see okay what are
we going to do and I remember on the
plane speaking to our Norwegian
colleague who was with us most of the
time there'd acne under telling him
Dagon I'm a bit worried that I'm
actually not more worried because it
seemed to me like this is a big crisis
but we've had so many crises that you
get used to sort of crisis management
well when I think about it and how it
really it was an extremely tricky moment
I mean it is was the moment when
everything could have failed but I think
it's well worth looking closely at what
happened and I won't go into all the
detail except to say because I just
noticed yesterday that in John Kerry's
new book Kerry was extremely good to us
and very supportive over the peace
process as was the Obama administration
and everyone around in his new book he
says ah well you know the Colombians
found a way out of this and like the
Brits with brexit but the thing is that
unlike brexit nobody ever said that it
was about the no side never said we
don't want peace they never even said we
don't want an agreement
well they said especially to its most
authoritative voice who was a former
president Uribe who exerted such bitter
opposition to the whole thing and still
does he would say please don't break up
if we win don't break up the
negotiations what we want are
modifications to the agreement so when
we lost we went and talked to the FARC
and the FARC in what I thought was a
great
show of maturity we said look we have to
first acknowledge we we lost secondly we
have to make sure that the ceasefire
holds and third we have to recognize
that we have to make some modifications
to the agreement because we lost and the
FARC said yes so we produced the press
release saying this is what we're going
to do and next thing we went in the sack
with these guys
I said oK you've won you said you want
to modify certain things so tell us what
it is you want to modify in finally say
so the true democratic fashion so we we
had discussions over weeks and this all
the whole thing ended with a very
intense session at the Ministry of the
Interior at the end of October beginning
of November which lasted a full week
because we want to have a document on
black and white or what it was that they
wanted so we put together all the
proposals of the node side with them and
at the end we had a document with 60
with 60 boxes of the issues they wanted
changed and literally we look what about
on their arms plane to Havana sit with
the FARC and see what we could do and
honestly we managed to get changes on
almost every box except precisely the
issue of political participation where
they wouldn't budge this and you know
and that's what we're doing this peace
process we're not doing this peace
process to disappear from the world but
there's a return into something else or
this your political participation and so
we actually got about fifty eight of
those sixty things changed but when we
got back to Bogota and sat with the guys
on the other side and fallen president
anyway I mean at least to me was very
quickly clear that in the end the the
tribe they'd had in the referendum were
just too enticing to throw away that
political base and that they were
thinking naturally about the 2018
elections which is true exactly what
happened so unfortunately there was no
agreement who could have reached
whatever we had we would have done
that's my own view and on how do you
explain
to Colombians how this complex system
works well it's a huge challenge because
as you know and and you gave me part of
the answer the thing is if any of you
saw this the next day after the
referendum or the plebiscite the main
newspaper el tiempo published a map of
Colombia with two colors green and
orange orange was no green was yes and
which was all the heart of the country
the heartland the urban Colombia and
Green was the periphery of the country
so in fact the people that have been
talking about the real victims the
people that lived with the FARC on their
backs voted yes in many cases by a very
very large majority in the case of for
example Chaco which is the poorest the
pertinent in Colombia as you know very
hard hit by the FARC fully eighty-one
percent voted yes and those in the
cities who were suffering less and were
and those in the what you might call the
Oliva heartland they voted no and the
discussion is extremely difficult
because number one us with all referenda
and this is something we knew and it's
true more often than not they are there
about the current government and they
are about the issues so it's very
difficult to get people to think about
no no no this is not whether you like as
the government or not this is about this
issue and more significantly still it's
it's very still difficult to convey the
message say look if we want a peace
agreement then these are the best terms
you can achieve because no very less
signs a peace agreement to go to prison
it just it just doesn't happen they'd
rather stay where they are so if you
rather have them around for another 20
years
10,000 armed men then we can give
everything up but it's it's very very
hard work because again it's what I was
trying to say if you measure things
against or with an ordinary standard
well of course you can say well you know
they should have got 40 or 60 years in
prison well yes but that wouldn't have
happened anyway if you measure it
against what used to happen in the past
Columbia where there was for example the
m-19 there wasn't with a few exceptions
there was a general amnesty or what
happened in Central America then then
this is demands a huge amount from the
FARC in fact the FARC are the first
gorilla that is signed an agreement
where they say they will go before a
tribunal tell the truth expose
themselves to ending up in prison if
they don't tell the truth and serve this
this particular sentences but it's a
complex story it's a complex story that
when it gets mixed up with politics it's
difficult to convey well as you know
enormous admirer of the peace agreement
and of your work what I wonder whether
this is some kind of conceptual
confusion that really somehow amass the
achievement the peace agreement and I
feel it it occurs it to a point in your
presentation one is the classification
of it as on conflict now when you call I
mean everyone knows guerrilla military
operations involves all conflicts but I
think this particular legal
classification as a armed conflict and
bringing in the laws of war means that
it is not unlawful to kill a government
soldier that is the ID the images that
there's a war between the government
military operation is under guerrillas
and if they just know I mean they can't
kill civilians that's one of the
features of the laws of war so
immediately by the classification as on
conflict you're forgiving the killing of
soldiers because that is not unlawful
under the laws of war
so there's a little bit of forgiveness
in that classification
the second period of classifications
that has built in is the concept of
transitional justice now the concept of
traditional justice really didn't mean
less justice there was an attempt to get
justice in a situation in which there is
a change of regime from one regime
saying dictatorship to a democratically
elect that's the transition you're
talking about it's not a transition to
peace that's nice transitional justice
but I think this conceptualization of
transition justice is like in your
account is you're you're you're giving
up on justice a little bit you know it's
you're trying to what your conception is
yes we didn't get justice we got peace
what we're getting as much justice as we
can in order to get peace so I mean and
and both of these things I think sort of
created this miracle of the amount of
peace agreement but somehow among
friends Sergio you have to acknowledge
that you you you didn't quite get
justice you've got the case but you
didn't get justice okay well that's a
very good debate as always
so on the first technical point which is
very interesting as you know much better
than I do
Fresno face a different protocol to of
the Geneva Convention says that none of
the above
will prevent a state from from judging
and applying the rule of laws it's it's
fit so during the conflict we never gave
up on the idea that it was unlawful to
kill a soldier and we could prosecute
the FARC constantly for that and we did
so that's true but it's also true
that unless you understand that you now
in a peace negotiation and you have to
see what were the most serious crimes
that happened you need to use the
structure of the armed conflict by the
way without that everything we did
during the war would have been unlawful
because in Colombia we were constantly
for example as one of the few countries
in the world where the Air Force was
constantly not just bombarding its own
territory but killing its own citizens
were the FARC members and the only
reason why it could do that is because
it was operating under iho and in fact
the Colombian Armed Forces and I worked
on that hard myself when I was Deputy
Minister of Defense that made a huge
effort to incorporate IHL and to work
with the ICRC into their doctrine and
otherwise they couldn't operate it or
you couldn't have done numbers or lots
of other things so in fact the practice
was that and it was recognized as such
by the by the Constitutional Court on
the other hand on a political level I
see your point of course and that's one
that that is one of the main
difficulties of the whole thing then
unless we have a horizontal negotiation
you don't have an agreement because
that's a negotiation but that a lot of
people not just the most bitter
opponents field hmm it's still funny
still funny because you know we are the
government of the state and this guy
should be paying for what they did and I
understand that fully if you like but
without that we couldn't have got an
agreement and only a transitional
justice well I mean it's again it's it's
an issue of how you define things in how
they evolve but in Colombia they were
already strong presidents President to
leader himself has been so bitterly
opposed to this when he started
negotiating with the paramilitary his
government in 2003 first produced a
draft bill which was far more lenient
than anything we did and then
subsequently Congress took that and and
made the conditions harder and then the
Constitutional Court reviewed that and
added more things but still it was still
the same eight years that the
paramilitary got because you are doing a
transition to peace so undoubtedly is is
different and one can have a big debate
on what one should call transitional
justice on the other hand I'm actually
quite optimistic that with the way
things have been set up now and with the
way that respect the new tribunal is
developing its own doctrine following on
this issue of what I called
conditionalities there you may see
things that have never happened
elsewhere such as people really
understanding that they have to tell the
full truth and they have to go look at
South Africa which is in South Africa
was an amazing thing and admire Belen in
many ways set the standard for a truth
commission but as many of you know
hardly and in will correct me
hardly any state agents turned up at the
truth commission mmm here you have the
possibility of doing something that is
actually when you talk to victims and he
cannot talk about victims in general
they're not a homogeneous group and and
someone one thing and others want
another thing and and there's naturally
there right but on the whole I think
it's probably hard to say that what
people most want is to find out the
truth
what happened an explanation and
acknowledgement and and this system will
provide much more of that so again it
comes to your own definition of justice
if you understand justice in this case
as getting the most truth you can for
the victims and the most acknowledgement
and the most reparations and some
justice and you add all that up if
things work well I think it's more for a
lot of victims than what they may get
from just seeing somebody sitting in
prison for eight years which is what
happened with the paramilitary I
appreciate all of that I understand your
point
whether the moment has comments were
thinking about their immature is to make
an acknowledgement how in some ways
these legalistic categories of all
conflict registers have been transcended
rather than falling back into the Canon
established category is somehow to
acknowledge forthrightly of the creative
process that took place in Nevada I mean
I can't make a political calculation but
I mean I think that's part of the
miracle is that you I mean even though
you make gestures towards these legal
categories somehow under the pressure of
circumstances you broke through the
legal forms and created a distinctive a
distinctive model yes I think that's
probably what the first question was
referring to me how can we do a better
job of explaining disaster thank you
it's not a privilege to have you here
and especially to congratulate you on
your work on victims participation in
the process I have two questions if I
may first of all you briefly touched
upon the close supervision of the ICC
and I wanted to ask you in particular if
you could tell us a little bit more
about the relationship between your
office and the OTP in enduring the mana
process and how the shadow of the ICC
shaped the negotiations on
accountability that made it into the
Accords and secondly moving past the
agreement one of the things that's
really I think remarkable in terms of
thinking about the legacies of conflict
is the fact that just this year in loan
there's been almost 200 human rights
defenders and peace activists who've
been targeted and killed throughout the
country and this is of course a trend
that was true before as well so looking
to the future I'd be curious to hear
what you think should happen with
respect to that sort of legacy of the
conflict because in many respects it
serves
why is in the face of the principle of
non-repetition and how we think about
the enduring peace that comes from the
agreement thank you okay on the first
question of the ICC which is actually
very interesting because in my view I
honestly think this the ICC has the most
effect the most beneficial effect one it
doesn't have to do anything because the
relevant country is actually making sure
that justice is administered and that
the rule of law prevails and curiously I
have a Dutch friend who's writing a PhD
thesis on this with the slightly
perverse but interesting thesis that the
ICC works best in the countries at least
needed because they're institutionally
strong enough to actually do things but
the fact that they know they're on the
rises you supervision and Columbia might
be the classic case does lead everyone
to get more serious about this and to
understand that things have to be done
and the game is not over yet because
they still need to see how things will
play out we need to see how sentences
will be served but I think on the whole
for from what I saw and I was myself in
touch a fair amount with the ICC
including with madam been sued up on a
number of occasions I think they've
taken a very mature and responsible
attitude of the the deputy prosecutor
will turn up he was just recently bought
a but he would go to bother to make some
statements remind everyone see the
courts everyone's aware of what the
parameters are and that's what I meant
by by by turning the constraints into
neighbors and to say look this is the
reality this is what's going on we need
to do something that can still be seen
as being within the bounds of what we
committed to even if as Owen might say
well it's not all exactly the same thing
so I think that has actually been a very
productive relation and I think that the
ICC has behaved in a very intelligent
way
in the case of Colombia but we need to
wait and see what what happens because
as I said the game is not over and we'll
see what it happens when people are
serving their sentences on the issue of
the human rights defenders which seems
would seem to contradict the whole
narrative we'll have been talking about
and it does of non-repetition is
precisely the great issue in the end the
problem in Colombia is a problem of
governance in the periphery and and the
FARC pulled out there's a vacuum there
were enough criminal organizations
around and illegal economies to feed
various kinds of groups and in that
context you got this rise in the number
of killings of what we'll call social
leaders and the whole thing is actually
quite difficult to understand and to
present because that all is happening
within a context of general pacification
of Colombia you see the general figures
for Colombia and we have the lowest
homicide rate in forty five years or
something like that
but within that general pacification in
those fringe areas where the FARC was
present you get the kind of turmoil
associated with change and before we
walked in here we were discussing
Professor Shapiro completely different
chapter but actually has a lot to do
with this which was how to which I spend
my time as ambassador in Brussels
working on its how to lure investment
into those regions because in the end
what he need is to get viable economies
you need people to get jobs you need to
lure them away from the coke economy and
so forth and that's a massive massive
challenge and it's also a massive
challenge because as we were discussing
before one of the really difficult
things about a peace process and you can
one can repeat this phrase a thousand
times one can stand on one's head and
people still will not listen just say
look signing a peace agreement is not
the end is the beginning that's one
thing that's one the really hard work is
going to
beginning and that's exactly what
happened to us everybody is so exhausted
and finally causes disagreement and and
somehow the energy is not there and it's
it's true I mean it also is the end of
the President Santos's government almost
eight years but we'll see what happens
yes sir every question that's born of
ignorance you stated with you stated
with great confidence that the FARC
quickly and efficiently disarmed so my
questions are how do you know that for
sure
and especially given its history these
view the FARC as a strong enough
organization to keep out any rogue
members who want to take up arms okay
the quick answer to the question one is
yes in question two is no so the yes is
we had as a government probably more
information on the FARC than any
government has faced the guerrilla has
ever had because we had just massive
amounts of intelligence we had literally
thousands of FARC members the mobilized
individually over the last 15 years and
the way it worked is actually run that
program when I was Deputy Minister of
Defense
it was called the humanitarian Dibble
ization program and the reason by the
way why the FARC especially hated the
word dehumanization because he
associated with the Ministry of Defense
program but what it meant is that it
opened the door for you to get out of
the war and go back home
and each one of those persons would be
interviewed in depth and if he was it
didn't have any legal problems he would
he would he would go home so we through
that and the fact that we found frankly
over the last 10 years one one of the
advantages of technology FARC you
started using laptop so you find one
laptop after the next so you really have
a very clear picture of of the weaponry
and the information we're getting from
latarian police intelligence matched
very closely the figures of what we got
so that's why I say that confidently on
the second question of whether a rogue
member could not take up arms again well
I think that I don't think it's very
likely at all that that some FARC
members will genuinely take up arms
again and think they are starting a new
insurgency to topple the government
because as some of them have said even
some who are who may have been on the
verge of becoming rogue members is you
know we couldn't manage that with ten or
fifteen thousand volume we're never
gonna get this with so so the answer to
that is I don't think that's going to
happen what could happen and to some
extent is happening is that because you
still have this very serious problem of
the coca fields and we have people who
have got used to basically behaving like
warlords in certain regions the best
known currently in Colombia this guy
called him King party who actually was
in Havana the peace process old for
commander who deserted the peace of the
peace process is very early on so you
know he thinks you know I can go out to
his region I can still sort of run
things
I run the Coco economy I extort people I
am the law of the land why should I be
doing in heels and that what is known in
Colombia is the dissidents the number is
growing it's not as large as a rather
responsible New York Times article
recently said because it had bad sources
but it but it's not as significant by
any means may well be over a thousand
and so you have to pay attention and in
and things hang on a lot of things
people get very mean they're still
nervous just like as we were saying that
the peace process actually begins with
the signature the other image or phrase
that I used to use was you know you have
to see a piece purses like a living
organism like little clan tree have been
constantly watering and you have to be
working it all the time and sending
positive signals and if you if you just
forget
about it then it can go the wrong way
certainly
so that risk is there yes there must
become we're talking about the military
process and how those members of the
apologize had eight years yeah
and that's perhaps where the Clemens had
in mind little bit when they went to the
boat and have no very biblical kind of
justice pit-a-pat - I you really think
that peace process can effectively be
empty non-repetition
when it's a half maybe it's a little bit
less than that all the comments aren't
willing to accept decision justice okay
so there are a number of questions out
for you for those of you who don't know
as I explained before what happened in
the negotiate first of all with the
paramilitary militias the government
started contacts very early on of
president earlier late in December of
2000 when Burma correctly of 2002 and
they started the mobilizing by the end
of 2003 most of them to mobilize around
five and six but with those guys even
though the government used all the
legislation that exists in Colombia that
allows a government to negotiate with
armed groups namely guerrillas actually
the first thing that the government
president really did was to change that
legislation so you didn't have to
atribute a political intent to the group
you were negotiating with because it
would have been it was intended
naturally for the guerrillas so they
changed that turned that into objective
criteria by the way funnily enough
despite the fact that they denied as an
armed conflict by using IHL criteria of
territorial control and so forth and and
based on that they started this this
talks but my main point is that there
wasn't really a negotiation I mean there
wasn't an agreement nobody's ever seen a
proper agreement signed with a
paramilitary saying we commit to this
and we are willing to sit in prison for
eight years that didn't happen
what actually did happen is that the
government in a way tricked them because
it presented a very soft bill in 2003 to
them and they started gathering and
moving into his areas and the commanders
moved first into this place we may
remember in Anacostia and when they were
already gathered whatever Congress
started changing the conditions of that
law and then the Constitutional Court
this so later on when they had already
mobilized so when they woke up they
found that the whole thing had been
changed and that the deal was now they
had to sit in for eight years and kill
him so that's why I say it's not really
comparable that said I think you're
right obviously from a common sense
point of view most people don't know
this story and they say okay well this
guy is 1 for 8 years to prison or they
got why the fart not going for 8 years
as well well the long explanation is the
one I just given what the histories of
the paramilitaries but I think at the
same time and still I mean we need to
see how things play out but I think if
if things are done in a genuine way I
when I was Peace Commission I also had
responsibility for those paramilitaries
who were in prison not for the
reintegration
but for nominating them to be part of
this justice and peace process so we
actually worked quite hard on that and
especially to make sure that all the
legal stuff was in order and when you
see what happened I mean you might also
think well I mean is that a good deal is
that just that's real justice so so some
guy who just sits in prison for years
does nothing in many cases the guys were
making the mid-ranking commander's many
ended up with serious drugs problems and
so forth and they get out and you and
that is actually good justice instead of
having them somehow be much more
productive towards the end of the Peace
browsers and with the victims and being
obliged to tell the truth and help find
the disappeared and so forth so I I
actually am not convinced by that but it
is politically was a problem yes
mr. hodda me just thank you very much
for being here I'm honored to be
attending this stop
I have some questions regarding
consideration considering that there was
an institutional and policy framework
for the reintegration process why is it
different under the peace agreement what
do you see as the main current
challenges of the reintegration process
and what are your views on the fact that
some Clarke leaders have been really
abandoning the integration so
institutional and policy frameworks that
existed before the agreement for the
reintegration of demobilized okay
okay well that's a very interesting
question for any of you who may be
interested in this disease of
reintegration because the government in
the case of the paramilitary took quite
a bit of time to get its act together in
fact too long and lost a lot of
mid-ranking commanders who then became
the heads of these new criminal
organizations we call back creams in
Colombia but it's one said you did get
its act together and put together an
institution that looked after the
reintegration of the paramilitary and
did it quite well with one major
difference and that is that it treated
all of the people as individuals number
one I it was not prepared to deal with
with a more collective or associative
model of integration and number two it
did it mostly in urban contexts where
it's actually much easier to find
somebody a job provide him social
services various times etc the challenge
with the FARC is that even though the
basic conditions they were given are the
same or even this bit better in terms of
getting for a number for about 24 months
a monthly allowance - for their needs
and helping them with her
prepare for whatever is it used to do
and getting some money for a project and
so forth
the thing is that in the case of a FARC
this is a big difference between that
and what happen with the paramilitary in
the case was a fart this happened
actually as part of a real peace process
my view but primarily we didn't have a
peace process we government is
negotiated with the militias to de
mobilize that was it in this case you're
actually running all of these programs
in the countryside number one number two
the FARC mostly want to stay in the
countryside and not move to the cities
not all of them because nobody's obliged
to stay where they were but but most of
them us you know come from deep rural
areas you refer to them leaving this
reintegration zones and that's a
difficult question to evaluate for those
of you who don't know we had to with
great efforts set up set up 26 what you
normally would coke on containment areas
for disarmament which were there and
turned into centers for reintegration
but nobody's obliged to stay there I
mean you can stay there and hang out
there and suddenly may decide that you
want to change your life and just as
some may say no we'd rather work here
the land and be with my old comrades and
work with the communities and set up a
project and and and sell milk or
whatever it is all those may say no I'd
rather get myself an education and go to
the next large city and enroll somewhere
so it's actually not a indicator
necessarily of how well or badly it's
going what is true is that the
governance had problems in going beyond
the usual model you are deluded to and
supporting a more ambitious model of
reintegration that profited more from
the kind of investments that had to be
made in the countryside and made more
use of his people and and yeah just a
quick anecdote work what for me was
particularly if I make is this
expression kind of moving moment in
Havana's that were were towards the very
end of negotiations in 2016 were talking
to the Secretariat guys and one of them
was one of those hardest of the
hardliner says well you know what we
want to do is actually be out there in
this region and help the state
institutions and participate in these
programs and you think oh no you know
these these were Marxist guerrillas who
were combating you and they now want to
become civil servants almost which to me
is a very good thing but people don't
entirely appreciate well they don't know
perhaps what it needs to be a civil
servant but yes that's something we need
to work harder on that that model and
and this again for those of you who
don't know too much about Columbia we do
have these massive problems of this of
this classic urban-rural divide it's not
again it's not black and white the
example but that has been always very
Pro Peas and voted for the peace
agreement and so forth but on the whole
on the whole it is true that because the
problem had received we had been
receding and been felt really seriously
only in this peripheral areas it's it's
always quite difficult to build an
emotional connection from the people in
the cities to the problems today one
across the board I mean they're not for
example in the universities ISM in very
interesting student movement and
students who who've been going out to
those reintegration centers and doing
things but to some extent even today
frankly I would have expected a bit more
even after losing the referendum I would
expect a bit more kind of enthusiasm and
sometimes you find that even our own
universities are not as engaged as they
should be yes I'm sorry
and yes people you know they also are
not very involved
listen I can't hear you slow down and
you I know you'll be
how are you making the government
authorities accountable to the group so
they know a little bit more about a
confidence process building how do you
sit down with that power can just start
you know saying how did you get
confidence with them so on the issue of
government authorities now interestingly
one of the reasons why this this
ambitious creative system has so far
worked is because it has had also the
support of the military there is there
is there's a very sensitive discussion
at the moment in Colombia because one
political party the center of Makati Co
has been insisting and trying to pass
legislation and already did one bit of
legislation to create a kind of separate
chamber for the military as part of this
process
now most people who know anything about
this realize that this is this is
completely lunacy and goes straight
against the interests of our own
military because it creates great legal
and security because it looks like
you're shielding them by creating a
special chamber but interestingly our
own military want to participate and
they're going before the this
jurisdiction now the truth is that part
of that is because also the Colombian
justice system the ordinary courts the
prosecutors have been serious in
prosecuting the crimes committed by
state agents so that faced with the
possibility of having to serve a very
long sentence or participating in this
transition system they're raising their
hands and saying I want to participate
in the transition system what we need
what we need to see is how that's going
to play out because the conditions or
conditionalities for them are not
different than from the FARC and they
will have to they will have to do the
same things to tell the truth
reparations and so forth which again is
something that it's unusual and that has
normally not happened with state agents
in peace processes and the issue of
trust and then how was it built that's a
very long story but the main thing I
would say is that in a peace negotiation
in my experience Trust is built by what
you do and not what you say but your by
your behavior and the results that the
proces itself produces so simple example
the we did the secret talks which had
never been done before
Colombia's many of you may know is a
completely media mad country where
everything is leaked everything's in
news in the radio every morning from
6:00 in the morning on and we actually
manage to negotiate for almost six
months in Havana without leaks until the
very very end it was one at the very end
so you see uh you know the other guys
are being serious
they're not leaking this they are
behaving properly and vice versa and
then the way it worked because it was
such a long and difficult negotiation
you know the agenda had six points and
so you after the first six months of we
first did the the framework agreement
that took about six months then we
started work on the first point of the
framework agreement which was the issue
of rural development and after about six
months we reached our first agreement
and then another six months we reached
another agreement on the issue of
political participation and so forth in
what I call an incremental strategy so
that the more results you achieved the
heart it was for either side to think
that they were going to pull out of this
or they had no trust because they could
see they were ready to commit it to the
process now it didn't mean that it was
guaranteed you were going to get a
result there were some issues
particularly this justice issue where
things could have collapsed or this
issue of political participation I've
been alluding to but on the whole I
think as a friend of mine you knew a lot
about these things told me
before we even engaged the FARC what you
actually trust is not so much the person
by the process you need if the process
works well then each both sides have
trust in the process so I know there are
more questions but we're out of time
just before bringing those machetes to
it and just to remind everybody there
will be a reception upstairs to
immediately fall into which everyone is
invited
[Applause]
[Music]